walk in to this video okay i want the
sicilian and I want blood well bah okay
and then some some guy plays g3 against
me okay
yeah I wanted some some some opposite
side castling or something crazy and
then you get the CC c 3 sicilian it's
not good okay playing for night b5 stuff
okay let's just just go back yeah that's
not very exciting but I'm perfectly okay
of course 95 am I not grabbing maybe
checking the bishop here only three
maybe 96 that's okay now i'm a bit ahead
on the clock at least
okay i want to get rid of this this
bishop it's very annoying and putting
pressure on you seven so i want to drive
it away five maybe my five could end up
being very weakening but ok the Bashar
the knight on d4 is really really an
annoying piece so maybe I need to do
that ok trade off and rook e8 make him
play rook e1 it's a bit difficult to
carry five him with the with the bishop
here that's not not so great
yeah he's attacking it really often
I cannot even play Boucherie 6 cm
hmm
Bishop takes root area this is not
really problematic I have half sick so I
think I can I can play this technically
the Palo Verde kid has the name Paulo
were the kids whatever okay I thought he
could not do that I always thought takes
first but this is of course possible he
should be three bishops e7 that sets
totally useless what was thinking here
and care
amazing I just gave up e5 for basically
nothing maybe I have some activity here
with rookie too I can take him but well
he rocked it to as a good move okay
seven rock t2 gets very active a passive
move certainly won't won't suffice okay
i'm king here i can go to see too so
maybe i can activate the activate here
with a form
yeah it's not so easy for him I think
roop see one work T 2 is a problem kinky
one may be kinky one but I play a form
king you 1 rooty to could could be could
be possible
hmm something else entirely hmm okay a 4
C 5
okay I cannot move the night already 97
91 that's a problem and it's always a
problem really if i go to d5 i can take
them
now again it can you play I can play
night before here time morning didn't
see this which is probably not a
decisive but
OOP t7s still good for what
I can just approach with the King
unfortunately yes we could be six coming
or barrier thing so in so now very easy
check
I can I can I can cannot stop the
language resigns so how did I lost the
scale I just blundered e5 basically and
then somehow I got slight activity but
see force was probably quite good but
King you one was also strong yeah I
really don't have a defense I mean in
addition he had night before he ever
just much easier and here it happens to
be winning as well now they have no
defense here the king is is better
involved him and he's got the look on
the seven there's no way to to hold that
thanks for watching